merci beaucoup avec nous en plateau
également un max dubois bonsoir vous
êtes président de l'association air et
d'hommes république et développement
outre-mer ancien coordinateur de la
campagne en marche dans les outre-mer
c'était en 2010 est depuis je crois vous
avez pris un petit peu de vos distances
avec avec le parti des manuels macro est
ce que cette crise en guadeloupe elle
était prévisible
alors j'ai pas pris de distance avec le
parti des manuels mais cran parce que
moi j'ai jamais adhéré en marche donc je
sais en tout cas pas la république en
marche
et ma solidarité que le président
république encore aujourd'hui est totale
il n'y a pas de débat sur le sujet
j'exprime des différents je vous dirais
lesquels mais en tout cas je suis encore
convaincu par emmanuel macron je suis
donc un maquereau nist mais pas intégrer
à la république en marche voilà
ce petit point est en fait et ce qu'il
représente
la crise était prévisible ça c'est très
difficile à dire ce qui est clair c'est
que lorsque est arrivée cette crise du
coffee d'il ya eu une communication
désastreuse essentiellement de la rs
d'ailleurs dans plusieurs territoires
d'outre-mer où on n'est pas passé à
travers les gens envie de dire les codes
que l'on trouve dans les territoires
d'outre-mer en fait il aurait fallu
passer à travers les présidents de club
de football à passer à travers tous ceux
qui s'occupent de la jeunesse à travers
les associations qui sont extrêmement
importantes et ne pas avoir un mot
d'ordre qui est un mot d'ordre qui a été
perçu comme un impératif et par principe
parce que les territoires d'outre-mer
ont une histoire et bien cet impératif a
été extrêmement mal reçu ça c'est le
premier point à ce que les élus locaux
ne sont pas crédibles non les élus
locaux sont tout à fait crédibles et je
me suis
je me suis retrouvé tout à l'heure
avec ary chalus ce le président de la
région guadeloupe qui a été élu très
brillamment pour une deuxième fois donc
la crédibilité pas à mettre en cause
simplement il n'y a pas suffisamment de
discussions entre les services de l'état
qui sont qui représente l'état en région
et puis les élus locaux ça c'est clair
et un moment donné il est vrai que ya
parfois des ruptures de discussions ou
les services décentralisés de l'état
s'exprime prennent des décisions sans
trop en parler autour d'eux et ça c'est
pas une bonne chose c'est toxique j'ai
eu également je vous renvoie également
une étude qui a été faite et que tu ais
faite en septembre par pas par un
cabinet de
d'études qui a fait donc une étude sur
les raisons pour lesquelles le le coc
vis d'eux était mal la fin les réactions
pour le côté mal à accepter est ce qui
ressort c'est que les gens quelque part
ou peur aujourd'hui de la vaccination
pourquoi parce que en profondeur il ya
un manque de confiance aujourd'hui parce
que la manière avec laquelle on a
présenté le sujet donnez pas confiance
aux gens pour aller sur vacciner on
parle souvent du scandale du chlordécone
à ce propos est ce que ça fait partie
des raisons pour lesquelles il ya cette
défiance ans dans la vaccination luis ce
fait si ce cas était
aussi est couvert par les différents
états donc aujourd'hui on dit aussi pour
le chlordécone circulez ya rien à voir
on a un peu perdu du papier enfin il ya
tout un tas d'histoires le maire
d'ailleurs de pointe à pitre harry
durimel est un avocat qui est en pointe
sur ce sujet là et effectivement ça ne
rassure pas la population parce qu'à un
moment donné pendant des décennies on a
raconté des histoires aux antilles est
donc aujourd'hui quand on leur parle de
du
du vaccin mais évidemment ça passe moins
bien donc là il ya cette situation de
départ mais finalement quand on regarde
les chiffres de vaccination d'aidé
soignant à l'hôpital et dans les maisons
de retraite ce chiffre est quand même
plutôt très élevé il est autour de 90%
oui donc c'est pas forcément le problème
qui est juste là en ce moment en train
de se jouer il ya aussi une crise
sociale qui s'étaient ajoutés à cela
comment où il explique cette crise
sociale est ce que c'est aussi le poids
des syndicats peut-être qui est très
fort en guadeloupe alors alors d'abord
une chose également quand on regarde
l'étude encore de cali stade dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure il ya aussi
un élément qui est un élément
extrêmement important c'est que les gens
aujourd'hui sont crispées
essentiellement sur le fait que les
soignants qui n'ont pas de passes
sanitaires sont suspendues de salaire et
dans un territoire dans lequel vous avez
une cherté de la vie très élevé des
salaires qui sont particulièrement bas
être suspendus de salers a une
signification extrêmement grave donc ça
c'est le point de crispation un seul
même si ça ne concerne que quelques
familles finalement
consommée par là donc ça c'est un point
que d'un point un point évident qu'ils
étaient mis en évidence par calista
teint donc c'est pas oui
on comprend bien que sur l'aspect
sanitaire le gouvernement va pas faire
d'exception pour la guadeloupe parce
qu'il y aura des répercussions sur
l'ensemble du territoire est-ce que ça
passe par des mesures sociales alors en
faveur pour réduire les inégalités afin
de mettre fin aux tensions ce qui est
très claire aujourd'hui c'est que
effectivement d'abord moi je veux dire
clairement que je dis qu'il faut se
vacciner jeu il faut faire la troisième
dose moi je vais faire bientôt la mienne
est que le pass and iter est quand même
un moyen d'aller on veut de manière
assez simple bon c'est une position
personnelle que je prends mais je la
maintiens et je les encourage
aujourd'hui d'accord tous mes amis au
gouvernement de faire une exception sur
toutes les questions sanitaires pour la
guadeloupe pour voir le calme
alors il a reporté un peu le délai le
brésil
après il ya aussi d'un côté il y à la
situation en guadeloupe qui est telle
qu'elle est donc il faut déjà sortir et
la sortie se fait effectivement par
l'envoi de troupes ça c'est un point
mais c'est pas suffisant et vous avez
dit une chose tout à fait juste là sous
jacent derrière ça il y à tous qui se
réveille comme inégalités on est
aujourd'hui la guadeloupe aujourd'hui
c'est un territoire dans lequel il y à
20% de chômage versus 8% ici en
métropole c'est considérable la
guadeloupe c'est 35 % de personnes qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
ça c'est une réalité donc il ya une
agrégation ensuite alors est-ce qu'il ya
eu une manipulation une utilisation par
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont à la tête des
mouvements de contestation
peut-être je je je ne peux pas
l'affirmer mais ce qui est clair c'est
que il faut arrêter de mettre les
balayures sous le lit nous n'avons pas
réglé les problèmes d'inégalité dans les
territoires d'outre-mer et nous ne les
avons pas réglé en guadeloupe depuis des
années la première réponse elle est
sécuritaire l'envoi de renforts tel
qu'on l'a vu donc hier et aujourd'hui ce
que c'est perçu comme une provocation ou
est-ce que ça peut permettre de ramener
le calme alors je pense que pour la
grande partie de la population c'est
ça rassure parce qu'effectivement c'est
extrêmement angoissant de voir
aujourd'hui autant de destruction de feu
de tableau personne n'est content avec
ça mais le problème aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement je ne crois pas que la
majeure partie de la population
suivent aujourd'hui les fauteurs de
troubles ça c'est clair mais pour autant
la population ne fait pas confiance
aujourd'hui à l'état et là il faut
travailler donc en appui aujourd'hui du
travail qui est fait pour rétablir
l'ordre il faut aller et discuter avec
les gens il faut discuter d'abord avec
les forces politiques qui sont
démocratiquement élu à commencer par le
président charles us avec lequel il faut
parler et les autres parce que ces
problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés essentiellement de chômage de
monopole vous avez une emprise
monopolistique de quelques entreprises
qui bouffent la totalité de l'économie
promet un d'accord donc ça il faut
absolument de sortir qu'elle est
aujourd'hui l'espoir d'un jeune
guadeloupéen les jeunes guadeloupéens
quitte la guadeloupe tous les ans vous
avez trois mille personnes qui quittent
la gaudeloupe par ailleurs la martinique
est également dans un même point
pourquoi parce que les jeunes n'ont pas
d'espoir pour continuer à travailler sur
place donc aujourd'hui il faut rendre de
l'espoir est là on n'a pas réussi ça
donc il faut se remettre au travail très
clairement il faut accepter le fait de
dire on n'y est pas arrivé donc il faut
de nouveau remettre l'ouvragé sur le
métier et il faut arrêter de balayer et
de mettre le lait valurent sous le dise
ça ça peut pas marcher longtemps ce
conflit on va l'arrêter mais si on règle
pas ce problème d égalité il va
redémarrer il va se réaliser merci
beaucoup max dubois est bien arrêtée sur
notre plateau vous êtes président de
l'association air et dormez vous
l'évoquiez un instant